the crowd chants send her back about
Ilhan Omar at a trump rally el Han Omar
demonstrates her anti-semitism and Nancy
Pelosi goes silent and Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
so the spy role to garbageland continues
apparently everyone has decided to light
themselves on fire both morally and
politically and I gotta tell you I'm not
enjoying it all that much I got to tell
you that I don't feel like the country
is becoming a better place through any
of this now I know that we are supposed
to just join into the tribal beatings I
know that we are supposed to say that
when bad things happen on our own side
it's not actually bad because we're the
middle of a tribal partisan fight and I
know that that applies to both sides I
also think that's a bunch of crap I
think that it is very important that
when something bad happens even if it
happens on your own side that you call
it out I'm not seeing that from
Republicans I'm not saying that from
Democrats and frankly I find it
upsetting and I find upsetting because
if we are going to share a country if we
actually feel that there is a future to
this whole or a republic thing and we
share a country then we are going to
have to have some common moral standard
where we say this right here this is
garbage and people shouldn't be doing
this and brushing it aside or saying
well you know if we act like garbage a
little in order so that we can win doing
that sort of routine I don't think is is
good for the country I don't think that
it is good for the soul of the country I
think it's good for us I think that it
is it is bad if we see each other in
such a nature that when we see something
that if the other side did a toss we
would be completely enraged but we're
doing it to the other side or vice versa
that we are going to be okay with it
because it advances our our interests I
just I don't think that that's all right
I don't think that that's okay I think
it's a dangerous in fact now this goes
for both sides and today's show is going
to be about how both sides have decided
to wink and nod at some of the worst
forces in their politics specifically
because they think the other side is so
evil
once you come down to the vision that
the other side is so evil that any means
necessary are on the table and and also
once you come down on the side that most
Americans are so vicious and/or vacuous
that your viciousness is going to
attract voters I think that you are
missing the point of most Americans in
the middle I think you're missing the
point of the
other side the idea of American politics
is to convince people who are in the
middle people who may not be watching
politics closely that your side is
correct your policy prescriptions are
right the most dangerous drug in
American politics and it really has
crept up in American politics I think
over the last 20 years or so I think
particularly since the since the Iraq
war is this vision that the way you win
elections is by castigating your
political opponents as if you're on the
left you casting it right wingers as
racist and stupid and bitter clingers
who cling to their gods and guns to
xenophobia and if you're on the right
then you castigate your political
opponents as people who hate the country
inherently as people who don't deserve
to be here as people who want the worst
for the country now you can disagree
with all of their policy prescriptions
you can believe that they're getting it
totally wrong
you can even believe they're getting in
the history of America wrong and that
that that perception of America's
history is dangerous and problematic but
that is a judgment about the thought it
is not a judgment about the person and
what we are starting to see is that the
most effective mode of American politics
may be character attacks but character
attacks are also the most effective mode
of breaking apart the politic that if
you attack somebody else's character on
a routine basis and by that I mean
suggesting that there is no place in
America for people like X if you do that
then you are contributing to something
that is really dangerous in American
politics and on the other side if you
believe that the other side is so bad
this be the left if you believe that the
right is so bad that we can embrace the
worst aspects of our own political
program that we can embrace the most
extreme anti-semitism we can embrace the
most extreme anti-american history
ideals because we hate Donald Trump so
much you get yourself into trouble in
other words I think that we are fighting
fire with fire and so everything is on
fire I think that that's where we are
right now and it's bad it's no good
we're gonna get into all of this in just
one second first a rising geopolitical
tensions have led to a five-year high in
gold prices Iran announced it will break
the uranium stockpile limit that they
agreed to under the nuclear deal is it a
coincidence the gold prices have been
steadily rising since the tanker
bombings it isn't because as I've been
telling you for the past four years gold
is a safe haven against uncertainty is
it part of your plan it should be hedge
against too
inflation and hedge against uncertainty
and instability with precious metals my
savings plan is diversified and yours
should be to the company I trust with
precious metal purchases is Birch gold
group if you look back historically when
the bottom falls out of everything else
Gold tends to safeguard savings Birch
gold group has thousands of satisfied
customers countless five-star reviews
and a plus rating with the Better
Business Bureau contact Birch gold group
and get a free information kit on
physical precious metals see if
diversifying into gold and silver makes
sense for you it's a comprehensive 16
page kit and it reveals how gold and
silver can protect your savings they can
legally move your IRA and 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA if that is something you are
into to get that no-cost no-obligation
kit text been to 47 47 47 again text
been my name - 47 47 47 that's text by
name been - 47 47 47 okay so in order to
understand where we arrived at last
night in sort of the political realm we
have to go back to yesterday morning
because this entire unfolding narrative
has been a crap show from beginning to
end so AOC and Nancy Pelosi will go back
even further back to last Thursday
all this stuff happens inside a week now
it's insane last Thursday AOC and Nancy
Pelosi were in an utter utter firefight
they o see was suggesting that Nancy
Pelosi was a vicious racist Nancy Pelosi
was correctly suggesting that AOC is a
neophyte who doesn't know what she's
doing and has radical ideas she doesn't
know how to implement and both sides
were just going at each other hammer and
tongs and then President Trump on Sunday
decided you know it'd be great I'm just
going to insert myself right here into
the middle of this for no reason at all
with a dumb vacuous xenophobic possible
you know very ugly tweet at the very
least he jumps in and he says that the
new democratic freshman congresswoman
come from countries that basically are
hellholes and maybe they should go back
home and it turns out that only one of
those people Ilhan omar is actually from
a foreign country and also telling
people to go back to the country from
which they came is generally not good
for American politics telling people
that they should go back to their home
country suggesting that they're more
loyal to their home country than they
are to the United States that's bad
Ilhan omar does it to jews all the time
because she's not a great person because
she's because she says terrible things
on a routine basis I think she's an
awful Congress person there's no one
more anti Ilhan Omar
the United States on a political level
than I am it's a Trump jumps into the
middle of that he makes these comments
and then we get three four days of
fallout from that and then it starts to
move on the news cycle and a OC and
Pelosi starts to go at it again and the
Democrats file charges of impeachment
against President Trump and that fails
and then Ilhan Omar decides you know
what with my newfound fame with my
newfound political capital I'm going to
push out another extraordinarily radical
piece of the Democratic agenda of the
far-left agenda a piece so radical that
my own party believes it's anti-semitic
so this is how the news cycle started
yesterday Nancy Pelosi had just the day
before just on Tuesday Nancy Pelosi had
rammed through the House of
Representatives a resolution condemning
president Trump's tweets as racist and
there is a whole floor fight big hubbub
about whether Nancy Pelosi was allowed
to call the president's comments racist
on the floor of the house cuz it
violated house rules the Democrats
basically overruled the house rules and
said it's fine she can call the
president's tweets racist and she went
out there and she said listen we speak
truth to power right this is her our
thing we speak truth to power every
single member of this institution
Democratic and Republican to join us in
condemning the president's racist tweets
to do anything less would be a shocking
rejection of our values and a shameful
abdication of our oath of office to
protect the American people I urge a no
vote and yield back the balance of my I
was just going to give the general
speaker of the house if she would like
to rephrase that comment I had cleared
my remarks as a parliamentarian before I
read them okay so she's speaking truth
to power so much truth so much power and
all the rest and then she tweeted out in
this house we speak truth to power now
here is the problem for a lot of folks
on the right even if people don't like
President Trump's comments like I didn't
like president Trump's tweets and I
criticize them pretty heavily this week
even if you don't like those comments it
is a lie that Nancy Pelosi speaks truth
to power she's a partisan hack who is
using racism in order to the the charge
of racism in order to forward her
political ambitions but she's more than
happy to ignore bigotry inside her own
ring so Fiona Presley says something
racist over the weekend if I owned a
Presley
the black people are not really black
people unless they agree with Iona
Presley and gay people are not truly gay
unless they agree with Iona Presley and
Muslims are not truly Muslim unless they
agree with el Han Omar then Nancy Pelosi
has nothing to say
and in fact Nancy Pelosi has shown her
cowardice on these issues time and time
again which is how you ended up in a
position where the aoc wing was in a
fight with the Nancy Pelosi wing because
remember
Ilhan Omar Rasheeda Talib AOC they're
not hiding any of what they feel or
there's a peace over a daily wire from a
few weeks ago by Ryan Saavedra listing
out all of the things ohon omar has said
in 2012 she tweeted israel has
hypnotized the world may Allah awaken
the people and help them see the evil
doings of Israel but the Jewish state is
hypnotizing the world face anti-semitic
Trobe she also in a January interview
this year defended those tweets saying
they were the only words I could think
about expressing at the moment then she
said in an interview on CNN she didn't
understand why Jews would find her
anti-semitism to be offensive
she said that's a really regrettable way
of expressing that I don't know how my
comments would be offensive to Jewish
Americans and then after her winning her
congressional election she switched her
position on BDS she suggested that
Israel should not be allowed to exist as
a Jewish state this is a direct quote
a Jewish state Israel is not a democracy
and then she compared Israel to Iran
okay and she then continued along these
lines she embraced Linda Sarsour who is
a radical anti-semite obviously and then
there's Rashida to leave another member
of the squad to leave has promoted
anti-semitic conspiracy theories back
late last year she suggested that their
congressional colleagues only supported
a bill opposing BDS because quote they
forgot what their country represents
what country they represent this is the
United States so basically they're
they're in league with the with the Jews
and everybody has divided loyalty
according to rashida to leave if you
oppose BDS and then of course she came
out in favor of BDS boycott divest and
sanctions she said that she did not
support a two-state solution between
Israel and the Palestinians which would
presumably mean the destruction of the
State of Israel
she's been photographed with supporters
of Islamic terror organizations the
Washington Examiner has reported that
over and over and over she was
photographed with the Palestinian
activists who praised the terrorist
group
Hezbollah said Israel did not have a
right to exist and is called for Israeli
Jews to return to Poland I'll go back
home look at that well roughly three
million Jews were killed during the
Holocaust he was welcomed and offered
and he offered her a piece of art and
her swearing-in she belongs to a group
that frequently demonizes Jews and it's
Palestinian founder Maha Abdul Kadir
raise substantial funds for to leave for
her congressional campaign this is
Rashidah Talib so there's tremendous
amounts of bigotry inside the Democratic
caucus he Nancy Pelosi has said nothing
about any of that Nancy Pelosi has run
away and she's hidden with regard to all
of this stuff and we'll see how this
plays out for her in just one second
first let me tell you sleeping these
days kind of rough
let's be real politics is so ugly that
it's difficult to get sleep sometimes so
this is why you're betting quality
really needs to be the highest and
that's why I use bolt and branch
everything pull and branch makes from
bedding to blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton
it means they start out super soft they
get even softer over time you buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to a thousand bucks in the
store Boleyn brand sheets are only a
couple hundred bucks in fact they are so
good and so comfortable my wife and I
took all of our other sheets we throw em
out bowl and branch basically ruined
sheets for us because they're so good
everybody who loves who tries Bowl and
branch eats loves them shipping is free
you can try them for 30 nights there's
no risk no reason not to give them a try
to get you started right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bowl and branch comm
promo code Ben go to bull and branch
calm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets
that's bol l and branch comm promo
Claire Ben Bowlin branch comm promo code
Ben go check them out right now again
the sheet quality is incredibly high
don't just go down to your local
retailer and pick up whatever sheet has
the highest thread count that's not how
this works you need quality sheets bow
and branch comm promo code Ben right now
for 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets which is a pretty spectacular
deal ok so Nancy Pelosi as we say she
does not speak truth to power when it
comes to the bigotry inside her own
caucus so when L hon Omar said openly
anti-semitic stuff over and over and
over Pelosi's immediate response was
well you know she just uses English
differently like the language of English
the incident that happened was I don't
think our colleague is an anti-semitic I
think she has a different experience in
the use of words doesn't understand that
some of them are fraught with meaning
- what didn't realize but nonetheless
that we had to address okay but you
didn't address it you then passed a
resolution that did not name any of our
homeowners comments and instead
condemned hate more generally so how did
this play out well here's how played out
a month ago Nancy Pelosi the Speaker of
the House spoke at the American Israel
Public Affairs conference which is
pretty common there's a bipartisan
organization a lot of leadership is
Democrat over at AIPAC and Pelosi
appears and she talks about the boycott
divest and sanctions movement now BDS is
in fact in anti-semitic movement not
everybody who expresses support for BDS
can be said to be anti-semitic but the
movement was founded by anti-semites and
the movement itself is anti-semitic
meaning that the attempt to boycott
every Israeli product on the basis of
you don't like Israeli policy with
regard to the Palestinians is singling
out Israel in a way you would single out
no other country not only that it is
targeting Jews collectively which is the
goal it damages Arabs who live inside
Israel and who are citizens
and originally the BDS movement was
launched by a bunch of people who openly
stated they wanted to destroy the State
of Israel Nancy Pelosi acknowledged as
much at AIPAC here's Nancy Pelosi a
month ago declaring that BDS is
anti-semitic policy we must also be
vigilant against bigoted or dangerous
ideologies masquerading as policy and
that includes BDS
[Applause]
last week we introduced the Schneider
that would be Brad Schneider of Illinois
and neither that be Jerry Nadler of New
York
the Schneider never resolution in the
house that explicitly opposes the BDS
movement okay so there we are Nancy
Pelosi saying BDS is an Semitic and of
course she is correct about that
according to The Jerusalem Post there
are more than a hundred links between
the internationally designated terrorist
organizations Hamas and the Popular
Front for the Liberation of Palestine
with nongovernmental organizations
promoting the anti Israel boycott
divestment sanctions movement some of
which received funding from European
states and philanthropic funds according
to a new report by the strategic affairs
ministry more than 30 members of Hamas
and pflp hold senior positions in BDS
promoting nongovernmental organizations
and that's not all
BDS proponents are pretty obvious about
what exactly they believe about Israel
Omar Barr Goudie who is the founder of
the Palestinian campaign for the
academic and cultural boycott of Israel
says Israel is Palestine there's no
reason why it should not be renamed
Palestine meaning Israel should
disappear and presumably all the Jews
should be killed or deported Ronnie
Kasrils says BDS represents three words
that will help bring about the defeat of
Zionist Israel and victory for Palestine
Michael wash house key who's a BDS
activists he said peace or better yet
justice cannot be achieved without a
total decolonization one can say T's
ionization of the Israeli state get rid
of all the Jews so the folks who created
BDS were not shy about all of this a
Norman Finkelstein who is a holocaust
minimizer at best and BDS activists he
says there's no Israel that's what it's
really about
everyone who so everyone knows what BDS
is right Nancy Pelosi knows what BDS is
and even Ilhan omar knew what BDS was
when she was running for Congress
because she went out of her way to say
to her constituents that she would not
support BDS this is going back just a
couple of years
in the Middle East and Jewish people's
white release with the invention it's
also important for us to make sure that
we are going to a process that we're
doing Stinnett the postilions i believe
right now with the ppsimmons meant it's
not helpful in hitting that two-state
solution and so i won't forward to
making sure that they're utilizing and
being part of a conversation that gets
us closer so your motive then ill head
omar there is basically saying BDS is
not effective and that's why i won't
support it but she never said that it's
immoral or a semitic nancy pelosi did so
nancy pelosi knows full well that PDS is
anti-semitic and she has made room for
Ilhan Omar to be as anti-semitic as she
wants to be the natural consequence
yesterday Ilhan Omar's first resolution
since the whole squad fight broke out
was promoting BDS shocker we'll get to
that in just one second first hiring
used to be hard not anymore when someone
makes the slightest most minor
insignificant mistake here on the
production of the men Shapiro show they
know that we can get rid of them because
we have zip recruiter we can replace
them at any time zipper career.com slash
daily wire constantly giving you the
ability to upgrade your business now in
reality we're not interested in getting
rid of anybody we're always adding
employees and that's really where the
zip recruiter is useful zip recruiter
sends your job posting to over a hundred
of the web's leading job boards they
don't stop there as applications come in
zip recruiter analyzes each one and they
spotlight the top candidates so you
never miss a great match zipper career
is so effective that four out of five
employers who post on zip recruiter data
quality candidate through the site
within the very first day right now my
listeners can try zip recruiter for free
at this exclusive web address zip
recruit comm slash daily wire that's zip
recruiter comm slash Dai ly w ir e zip
recruit calm slash daily wire zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire if you're looking to save time
which means saving money there's only
one great way to do it when it comes to
hiring that is zip recruiter go to zip
recruit comm slash daily wire right now
and try them out for free zip recruiter
comm slash daily wire okay so yesterday
after a month after Nancy Pelosi said
BDS is anti-semitic ill hen omar
sponsored a resolution that compares
Israel to Nazi Germany and the Japanese
Imperial Empire in 1937 when they were
raping Nanking that was the resolution
that she sponsored yesterday and Nancy
Pelosi who stands up truth to power
nowhere to be seen
she's got nothing she's got nothing this
this resolution says quote Americans of
conscience have a proud history of
participating in boycotts to advocate
for human rights abroad including
boycotting Nazi Germany from March 1933
to October 1941 in response to the
dehumanization of Jewish people in the
lead-up to the Holocaust so Ilhan Omar
was a nary a word to say about the
Iranian nuclear program present nary a
word to say when it comes to I mean she
literally was asked yesterday or two
days ago to condemn al Qaeda on the
basis of an old clip of her that was
going around in which she was jokingly
referring to to al Qaeda and Hezbollah
and saying well why was everyone taking
them with different seriousness than the
US Army and she's kind of laughing about
it she refused to answer that particular
question she said that it was beneath
her dignity to answer that particularly
there's a woman who wrote a letter just
a few years ago advocating for lenient
sentences for people who are trying to
join Isis and and who routinely engages
in anti-semitic language and ideas this
same L hen Omar is now saying that
Israel should be boycotted because it is
like Nazi Germany and Nancy Pelosi is
nowhere to be found so this resolution
compares Israel not only to Nazi Germany
but also to the Soviet empire to the
Soviet Union and also to as I say the
Japanese Empire from 1937 to 1938 when
the Japanese Imperial Army was busy
conquering foreign lands and subjecting
its population to supreme human rights
depredations including mass murder and
mass rape it's just it's unbelievable
and Nancy Pelosi of course has nothing
to say about there's your truth to power
here's Ilhan Omar yesterday comparing
BDS to the tea party we must support
efforts to end the occupation and see
riches achieve two-state solution I
believe firmly that the path to peace
does not lie and a violent means this
week I introduced a resolution where
civil rights leader our colleague John
Lewis and Rashidah Talib
who know the importance of non-violence
movements it recognizes the proud
history of boycott movements in this
country dating back to the posts in tea
party we should honor these movements
and that history and then of course over
this weekend she proclaimed that Hamas
was a nonviolent group effectively she
said that Israel is fighting nonviolent
resistors you know like the terrorist
group Hamas that is firing rockets into
the center of Israel again not a word
from Nancy Pelosi so no truth to power
from Nancy Pelosi no shock there and of
course the Justice Democrats are
promoting this the squad is prone and
their first initiative in the aftermath
of this whole Trump is a bigot fight
their first move is to sponsor a bigoted
resolution that Nancy Pelosi herself
suggested was anti-semitic and Pelosi
has nowhere to be found is it any wonder
that folks thinks that Omar and Talib
and AOC and Ayane Presley are running
the show over there in the Democratic
House is that any wonder because it
appears they are Nancy Pelosi he's got
nothing to say about this and neither do
the Democrats have you heard a single
Democrat mainstream Democrat comment on
Ilhan Omar anyone you can't even get a
mainstream Democrats and comment on it
on an actual terror attack on a nice
facility by an Tifa let alone
criticizing Ilhan Omar for her bigotry
and anti-semitism none of them are going
to do that now here's the thing there
are Democrats who know that this is bad
stuff obviously they're just being
shunted off to the side so Jake Tapper
on CNN reported yesterday that Democrats
are feeling squeezed by the fact that
Ilhan Omar and the squad are being given
as much prominence because they're too
radical because they engage in overt
bigotry on a fairly regular basis and
they're Democrats in the house going out
what is all of this I have been spending
the day talking to a lot of Democratic
House members they are very frustrated
with the squad they are very frustrated
with them for any number of reasons you
heard in the introduction one House
Democrats saying we need to be talking
about bread-and-butter issues not the
president's tweets but others say they
don't want to be in the position of
defending things that they disagree with
from say congresswoman Johanna Mar right
I mean this is exactly what the this is
a position that the president and the
Republican Party who has backed him up
on this has forced Democrats into they
are painting the entire Democratic Party
with the same brush okay so again the
the
moderate Democrats are feeling that they
are being forced to embrace the
radicalism of Ilhan Omar so by yesterday
we are back to Ilhan Omar being so
radical that there's an invite inside
the Democratic Party and president Trump
seems as though he has moved away from
his ugly statements of earlier this week
about everybody going back to their home
countries and that nastiness it seems
like he has moved beyond that and he's
shifted his argument to instead if you
don't love the country you can leave it
which is hackneyed and old and in its
emotional argument but at least is not
that is voluntary you can leave if you
want right that's it that's that's an
emotional appeal that is not send her
back right that is not go back to your
home country get out right then that's
that's not the same argument quite right
so he had shifted that argument and he
was spending his day attacking Ilhan
Omar for her record and he basically
said exactly this right yesterday he
said if people want to leave the country
they're free to go anytime they please
no if people want to leave our country
they can if they don't want to love our
country if they don't want to fight for
our country they can I'll never change
on that no okay and then Trump made
pretty clear he was talking about he
specifically was talking about Omar in
her comments about the United States the
fact that she said some people did
something about 9/11
Trump went after Omar on a variety of
issues the RNC released a campaign ad
about the squad's extreme rhetoric so
this is morph now into a tripartite
battle between AOC and the squad for
supremacy in the house and dance and
Pelosi and then versus Donald Trump who
has created an alliance between Pelosi
and AOC for purposes of opposing from
right that was the battle as of most of
yesterday the RNC released an ad
highlighting how radical the squad are
so this features AOC and Talib and Omar
and Ayanna Presley States is running
concentration camps on our side never
again
if this organization is as fascist as
you have called it for summits fans you
have said it's fascist then why don't
you adopt the stance to eliminate it
your colleague who was at the border
with you compared the facilities to a
concentration camp do you agree with
that comparison absolutely no say the
lights do so wait well bring the fire we
are learning new details about the man
who threw explosive devices at an
immigration detention center Tacoma
Washington will you clean them and Tifa
for attacking a nice facility will you
condemn the antifa attack in Washington
over the weekend
will you think that man started just
walking right past the questioning okay
so this is a much more cohesive and
coherent attack on the squad right this
is attacking them on their policy this
is attacking them on the things that
they have said and then President Trump
launched an attack on Ilhan Omar that
the media really couldn't stand he
mentioned the fact that you may have
engaged in immigration fraud with her
brother now the actual accusation is not
that she engaged in immigration fraud
but that she was trying to engage in
immigration fraud so that her brother
could illegally emigrate to the United
States here was president Trump sort of
throwing off-the-cuff this this rippen
Ilhan Omar well there's a lot of talk
about the fact that she was married to
her brother I know nothing about it I
hear she was married to her brother
you're asking me a question about it
I don't know but I'm sure that somebody
would be looking at that yes the media
said no how dare he say this thing about
her being married to her brother
hey literally there was an article in
the Minneapolis Star Tribune which was
his mainstream newspaper as it gets
talking about
Ilhan Omar's marriage and exactly who
she was married to and why she filed
taxes as married to one person when she
was legally married to another person
the UK Daily Mail has a piece today
called I am legally married to one and
culturally to another how l hanim are
desperately tried to shut down
accusations of bigamy amid claims she
was briefly married to her brother to
commit immigration fraud while she was
still with her current husband say I'm
not legally married to two people but I
am legally married to one and culturally
married to another that's how Ilhan
Omar's campaign spokesman Ben Goldfarb
summarized Omar's conjugal Arrangements
in an email in August 2016 when Omar was
running for Congress and her advisors
were trying to stifle allegations of
double marriage with a man alleged to be
her brother
Omar supplied this email to the
Minnesota campaign and public disclosure
board investigation into her campaign
financing that investigation concluded
on June 6th it revealed that in 2014 and
Omar may have broken federal and state
law by filing a joint tax return with
her husband Achmed Abdullah sobbed asawa
and her see when she was married to
another man
conservative journalist in Minnesota
raised the bigamy allegations in 2016
and in fact there's another story that
is out today from pajamas media David
Steinberg has been the reporter who's
all over this over at pjo media pointing
out that the the marriage is is a mess
that all this marital stuff is a mess
he says immediately after being elected
to her current seat in 2016 Omar
allegations soon backed by a remarkable
amount of evidence that she had married
her own brother in 2009 and was still
legally his wife they officially
divorced in December 2017 the motivation
for the marriage remains unclear however
the totality of the evidence points to
possible immigration fraud and student
loan fraud representative Omar had
stated that she did marry British
citizen Achmed Noor Sayid Elmi in 2009
she said the allegation he's a brother
is absurd and offensive they say below
exclusive new evidence from official
archives high school records and
corroborating sources strongly support
the claim that Achmed Norris ie tell me
is indeed her brother as this implicates
representative Omar in multiple state
and federal felonies I've contacted the
US Attorney's Office in Minnesota to
submit all other information uncovered
during our investigation according to
official student enrollment records
archive by st. Paul public schools in
the state of Minnesota and Achmed and L
me was enrolled as a senior in the class
of 2003 at Arlington Senior High School
in st. Paul Minnesota from 2002 until
2003 he graduated and received a diploma
the enrollment record gives his birthday
both illa Hannah Mars 2009 marriage
document and her 2017 divorce
proceedings say that her husband was
born the same day as this person
registered Achmed and L me there was no
other person named Ahmed Northside L me
Achmed and L me or even alpha L me with
the birthdate April 4th 1985 in
Minnesota the man L had Omar married and
the 17 to 18 year old who attended
Arlington Senior High School are one and
the same
this person was a minor for most of the
school year his parents and legal
guardian
were listed on his enrollment records
along with his home address and
telephone number he shared that address
telephone number and parental authority
with Ilhan Omar so that is the evidence
that is being put out there so the media
say well Ilhan Omar's denied it isn't
that enough no that's not enough you
actually have to go and investigate and
do the journalism that you guys are
supposedly supposed to do so suffice it
to say there's a lot in Ilhan Omar's
background that is worthy of scrutiny
and her comments on a day to day basis
are egregious her policies are awful
things she says about the country are
garbage
she is the worst member of American
Congress and it isn't even all that
close I mean Russia to leave is pretty
terrible
AOC is pretty awful Ayana Presley is bad
there are lots of bad members of
Congress Ohana martyrs in the class by
herself when it comes to being a bad
member of Congress but she is a duly
elected member of Congress and
is where we get to the other side of the
aisle so the Democrats are happy to
defend bigotry and nastiness and
ugliness and stupidity and virulent
anti-semitism from members of their own
party they will not stand strong as
Nancy Pelosi has not stood strong on the
Republican side of the aisle this does
not justify the behavior of people who
are saying things to duly elected
members of Congress and American
citizens like send her back we'll get to
that in just one second first it's time
to be adults I mean I think our politics
could use a little bit more adulthood
sometimes that means doing things you
don't always like like thinking about
life insurance policy genius is the easy
way to shop for life insurance online in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find your best
price once you apply the policy genius
team will handle all the paperwork and
the red tape no sales pressure no hidden
fees just financial protection and peace
of mind policy genius doesn't just make
life insurance easy that can also help
you find the right home insurance auto
insurance disability insurance so if you
need life insurance but you just don't
want to deal with all the legwork head
on over to policy genius com it's the
easy way to compare all the top insurers
and find the best value for you policy
genius delegate what you hate especially
if you hate getting life insurance
listen its responsible to think about
death at this point in your life if you
don't have life insurance because god
forbid you should plot got from in a car
ahead to you in the middle of the street
and you leave your family with nothing
well then your family is gonna be pretty
upset not just about your death but also
about the fact that they don't have the
money to deal with it don't be one of
those folks go check out policy genius
right now they've made it really
convenient and easy for you policy
genius calm delegate what you hate
especially if you hate getting life
insurance okay in just a second we'll
talk about president Trump's rally last
night the good the bad and leave very
ugly and I do think that there was
there's a moment that was very very ugly
we'll get to that in just one second
first this Saturday marks the fiftieth
anniversary since we put first put a man
on the moon and in league with esoteric
radio theater we've put out a new
podcast called Apollo 11 what we saw it
immediately rocketed to number three on
iTunes Apple podcast it's still in the
top 10 a week later episode 3 in the
beginning is out right now host Bill
Whittle who's an author of pilot space
enthusiasts we had him on the show he
knows more about NASA than any living
human being of whom I am aware he will
give you the step-by-step journey of
what it took to get to the moon and what
happened when we got there and also how
things almost went horribly wrong it is
a
riveting podcast head on over to Apple
podcast or wherever you listen to
podcast subscribe today to Apollo 11
what we saw also your opportunity to ask
me a question live and in person it's
almost here next month we're taking our
backstage show on the road for a special
one-night only event August 21st at the
beautiful Terrace Theatre in Long Beach
California that is correct me daily
we're a god-king jeremy boring and
reclaim the execrable michael moles and
even more important than him the daily
wire merch table will be there why we'll
be talking politics pop culture most
importantly will answer your questions
from the audience it should be a blast
can't wait to see you there tickets are
on sale right now at daily wired.com
slash backstage including our limited
VIP packages that guarantee premium
seating photos meet and greets with each
of us a gift from me I'm shopping for it
right now just for you you never know
what it'll be I mean I think it's more
romantic and more so head on over to
daily wire.com slash backstage get your
tickets today I will see you there daily
wire.com slash backstage also please go
subscribe over at daily wear again as
always it helps protect us from the
nastiness of a left that seeks to
silence voices it doesn't like cease to
target our advertisers because they
don't like the fact that we're
conservative please go help us out over
at daily wire.com become a subscriber
for $99 a year or $9.99 a month we are
the largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
okay so all of this hubbub inside the
Democratic Party this back and forth the
AOC versus Pelosi then Trump jumping in
in a terrible fashion and then the
Democrats returning to attacking each
other and moving incredibly fast to the
radical left all of this leads up to
President Trump's rally last night
President Trump's rally last night is an
opportunity for him to make the case for
his own presidency and to yes to point
out the radicalism of the left without
reiterating the stupidity of his
original tweet on Sunday in which he
said that women who were born in the
United States or who are legal
immigrants to the United States with
citizenship and duly elected in their
districts should go back to their home
countries right he doesn't have to do
any of that and he shouldn't do any of
that because it's bad and it was bad
when he tweeted it and it would be bad
for him to reiterate it here but he's
you and Trump knows that by the way
which is why he shifted the argument
into if they don't love it they can
leave right which is the same argument
that people have been making for ever in
America love it or leave it it may not
be a good argument but it is a certainly
frequently common argument in the United
States and it is important to note that
that is well within the realm of
traditional political discourse given
the fact that Barack Obama's
administration called members of the tea
party terrorists and we are routinely on
the right called Nazis by members of the
media as mainstream conservatives
routinely called Nazis and bigots and we
are constantly it's constantly suggested
that we are unamerican and awful and so
saying people if you don't love it you
you can always leave that's not quite
the same thing as go back to your home
country to people who are born in the
United States and also to people who are
legal immigrants from places like
Somalia which really is one of the worst
places on earth
okay so Trump gets to make his case last
night and as I have said about President
Trump before President Trump is a
stand-up comedian what that means that
he reacts to the crowd that's in the
room if you've ever seen a Trump rally
in its entirety basically it is a
stand-up comedy act punctuated by
politics for an hour he goes out there
people say things in the crowd he reacts
to the crowd he's playing with the crowd
Trump really likes when the crowd likes
him and so I've never seen him under any
circumstances rebuke a crowd he's never
happened he's much more likely to egg on
a crowd than rebuke a crowd I've never
seen a situation where crowd says
something and he says guys guys guys
guys stop that like he's never done that
which by the way is something that is
useful in politics I've done it many
times where a crowd will do something
and I'll say guys he got like stop right
this happens at my college speeches
fairly frequently where a couple
thousand people will be there somebody
will get up to ask a question and people
will start boo the question will start
booing the questioner and I'll say guys
he need like stop let's actually hear to
the question let's treat each other
civilly here now I know that there are a
lot of folks on the right who are
harkening back to the days of John
McCain when John McCain was at a rally
and somebody suggested that Obama was a
Muslim and John McCain correctly said no
did Barack Obama is an American and he
is not a Muslim and that was right that
was the morally correct thing to do you
don't lose the election because of that
he lost the election because the economy
tanked two months before the election
and he lost the election because Barack
Obama was given better media treatment
than any candidate in the history of the
United States and he lost the election
because Barack Obama was uniquely
talented candidate he did not lose John
McCain because he didn't stand there and
nod as the person called Obama a Muslim
right that is not why John McCain laws
but there is this mythos that has been
built up around the sort of Trump McCain
comparison where it's the reason the
McCain and Romney lost is because they
didn't fight because they didn't fight
okay well there is truth I think to the
idea that McCain and Romney did not pull
out the hatchet and go after Barack
Obama with enough alacrity I think there
is truth to that but that does not
extend it to everything that they did
that was moral was them was them wimping
out like I don't think that's what
happen I think that there's a part of
the Republican Party right now a part of
the conservative base I was like well
John McCain lost because he because he
tempts down that sort of stuff no that's
not why he lost again the sound okay so
Donald Trump is is not the kind of guy
who is going to tell a crowd to pipe
down he starts off and he's revving up
the crowd right I mean it's it's a
campaign rally he's rubbing up the crowd
and he starts with some of his greatest
hits he starts kind of hilariously by
thanking Democrats who voted against
impeachment because highlighting the
Democratic split is obviously smart
politics the Democrats are so split over
Trump that yesterday there was a vote in
the House of Representatives to impeach
President Trump or to force a vote on
impeachment on President Trump and it
went down in flames ninety-five
Democrats have voted in favor despite
the fact that the impeachment resolution
did not even include a rationale for
impeaching Trump it didn't include a
legal rationale any high crimes any
misdemeanors it was basically that he
was just a divisive the the grounds for
the the grounds for the MP
or that he was a meanie right that he
had retweeted certain videos and that he
had banned transgender people from
serving in the military and then he
criticized NFL players who knelt during
the national anthem none of this stuff
is illegal none of it's a high crime or
a misdemeanor you may not like it but
it's not illegal so 95 Democrats voted
in favor because any excuse to impeach
Trump felt Billy's and then most of the
Democrats voted no so Trump thanked the
Democrats last night at this rally but
again I have to tell you this vote was
so big I have to thank many of the
Democrats I mean that was an amazing no
no I really do I respect him I really do
that was a that was a slaughter but many
of those people that voted for us this
afternoon and somewhat of a sneak attack
a real sneak attack many of those people
that voted force were Democrats and I
want to thank them because they did the
right thing for our country
okay so again the crowd and then the
crowd wraps it up because listen Trump
plays the crowd but the crowd also plays
Trump and that's part of the dynamic
here
okay Trump is very very good and they
traveled to whatever he wants which is
why Trump really should step in when the
crowd does something he doesn't like now
uh-oh so Trump continues his rally and
again Trump does have the ability to
step in and say to the rally crowd guys
Matt come on you're like just cut it out
right he does have the ability to I
remember a couple of years ago I spoke
at CPAC in the middle of my speech at
CPAC a bunch of people started chanting
about Hillary Clinton to lock her up and
I said no don't lock her up leave her
alone she's gotten all the punishment
she deserves she's wandering around in
the woods of Chappaqua right look you
you can do this right and Trump could
have played anything the crowd did as a
joke instead he's he's playing this
dynamic where he makes a joke the crowd
laughs he makes a joke the crowd laughs
the crowd starts chanting and he kind of
goes along with it that was the dynamic
at the rally last night
so Trump then went on to highlight all
of Johanna Omar's record which again is
fine okay Johanna Omar is a key member
of Congress from people saying well
she's just one of 435 yeah really is
that why she was on the cover of Rolling
Stone magazine is that why the entire
mainstream media are mirroring her
comments every week for the last several
is that why the New York Times when she
said something openly anti-semitic
suggested that she was just reopening
debate
about the role of AIPAC in American
public life because she's unimportant
like don't Gaslight us we know that
she's important the media have made her
important so Trump highlighting her
record is totally within bounds so Trump
goes off on L hen Omar's record and
everything he says here correct here he
is she smeared US service members
involved in Black Hawk Down
Omar minimize the September 11th attacks
on our homeland saying some people did
something I don't think so some people
did something yeah some people did
something all right she pleaded for
compassion for Isis recruits attempting
to join the terrorist organization she
was looking for calm down everything he
says there's true 100 percent of the
things he says there certain people are
angry about it but all of that is true
and all of that is fine and again he is
he is not incorrect to highlight her
record she's a leading member of the
Democratic Congress and Nancy Pelosi is
bowing before her and allowing her to
run roughshod over the rest of the
Congress and she's doing the same with
the squad and when she tried to stand up
the squad basically shouted her down and
from sort of helped them by highlighting
them and forcing Nancy Pelosi to back
their play so that's what led up to the
most controversial moment of the last
week in the middle of this rally Trump
is speaking about a Linamar and the
crowd starts chanting send her back and
play the clip and then I'll explain why
this is so wrong why this is an American
why this is bad has a history of
launching vicious anti-semitic screens
okay now this is where we have gone
across the line so this is what Trump
should say no not send her back vote her
out right that's where he should step in
and say something and he doesn't and
it's wrong of him not to do so here is
why he's we've gotten into the situation
Trump and the crowd are one-upping each
other so Trump back earlier this week
said that all these people should go
back to where they came from which is on
a logical level voluntary
self-deportation right if you don't like
it you can leave it also go back where
he came from I don't want you here go
back where he came from and this is now
morphed into the crowd chanting send her
back
Ilhan Omar as I've Illustrated
throughout this episode and I think over
the last year total I think l-head Omar
is just awful I think she is awful I
think she's a terrible Congress person I
think that virtually every word that
emanates from her mouth is toxic I think
that she says things about America and
says things about terrorism and says
things about Israel that are just
garbage in every possible way I think
she's an anti-semite
I think she hates Jews I think that she
is a discredit to the Congress of the
United States she's had at the same time
she is a duly elected member of the
Congress of the United States if you
don't like her you know you could do you
could run somebody against her and
defeat her you can defeat her agenda in
Congress you can point out than what she
says is terrible you can do all of those
things if you don't like what she says
there are plenty of ways to fight what
she says including the use of the First
Amendment you know maybe you don't like
the fact that she's an American she is
an American she's American as you are or
as I am her ideas may not be as good her
ideas may not be moral or decent but
that does not mean that she is not an
American she's legally she's a legal
immigrant American citizen who was
elected to Congress by the constituents
of her district send her back as in
deport her you can't deport American
citizens with whom you disagree and I'm
just gonna ask you for a second to put
the shoe on the other foot let's say the
Barack Obama in 2010 had said about a
tea partier that you should that I the
crowded at one of his rallies had
started chanting deport him how do you
think that would have gone would that
have been a good thing or a bad thing
would that have been a moral thing right
now people today are doing the same
routine that they always do with
President Trump and that they always do
with sort of the Trump
and that is guys you can't take them
totally seriously I mean it's a crowd
chanting and sure it's just a crowd
chanting sure it was probably some dolt
in the crowd who starts chanting and
then a bunch of people start chanting
because this is what happens when you
have large crowds of people nearby right
there's a mentality that sets and where
people just start chanting I don't think
people thought through I don't I don't
think it's a bunch of people in their
crowd who are sitting there thinking
through yeah you know should we or
should we not call for the deportation
of an American citizen I really don't
think that's what happened I think
somebody started chanting sent her back
on an emotional level and then everybody
started chanting sent her back and then
Trump just stood there and took it
regardless the chat can still be immoral
and the idea that you're supposed to
deport people with whom you disagree no
matter how atrocious their ideas those
ideas are not criminal hey we do have a
First Amendment Johann Omar is
exercising her First Amendment rights
you don't believe or believe in or agree
with the First Amendment if you believe
that people should be deported for their
public views that are not incitement to
violence that are not that are people
don't get punished for speech in the
United States not by the government it
can be punished socially they can be
punished in the ballot box but this is
it's very disturbing and bad stuff now
listen I understand the frustration of
people on the right who are like well
why are you condemning them why won't
you condemn I spent the first 45 minutes
of the show condemning Pelosi okay I
understand people why what the media are
paying outsized attention to a crowd
chants
why won't they pay attention to the fact
that Democrats for years called
Republicans Nazis and AOC says it's a
concentration camp down on the border
and members of Isis are like Nazis I
share your frustration obviously because
I've sounded off on it I share your
frustration too but just because the
other side is doing a bad thing does not
mean that you should do a bad thing and
yes it is morally wrong to suggest that
Ilhan Omar should be deported it is
morally wrong to suggest that an
American citizen no matter how much I
just like her no matter how much I
dislike her ideas should be deported
this is still a country where
disagreement is supposed to be met with
disagreement not with threats of legal
action and again if you say well oh well
it's just a crowd the crowd chants
things it's like shouting at the umpire
at a baseball game everybody's there to
have a good time all of that is is fine
to an extent but if you start shouting
at the umpire to die you've done
something wrong and if
the and if the President of the United
States who's supposed to represent all
Americans is up there not saying
anything that's wrong to the president
should have stopped this and he should
have stepped in and he should have said
no if she doesn't love it she can leave
it right I mean that's his line right he
could has just said that he could've
said if she doesn't love it she can
leave it and also people shouldn't vote
for her you know vote her out
there are a lot of things he could have
said this is a it was a bad moment and I
certainly hope that that Trump pulls
back from the brink of all of this
because it's bad and it's ugly but again
what to a certain extent he sort of
trapped by his own words I mean earlier
in the week he did the whole go back to
her home country and then the crowd
takes it a step further and so now we
have everybody taking it a step further
just like in the Democratic Party
you've got the Democrats saying Johann
Omar she's not anti-semitic she's just
Unversed in the use of words and so she
says something more anti-semitic and
then they're like well is she really
anti-semitic and then she doesn't think
more anti-semitic somebody has to put
the brakes on this stop this crap
somebody has to put the brake on this
somebody has to be a responsible adult
in the room it's not good for the
country forget about just the election I
I care about the election two guys I
care about twenty twenty two you think I
want Elizabeth Warren or khamel Harris
to be president do you really think that
no I did there's little in this world
that I dread more than the idea of that
happening and by the way I think one of
the ways that you make that happen is by
alienating every suburban voter in
America with the most extreme rhetoric
you can possibly imagine on the right I
think that is probably a mistake
electoral II well beyond that you know
what I really do dread I dread that we
are coming to the point in the country
where the obvious solution to your
opponent supposing you is to suggest
that they are the worst human beings who
have yet walked the earth there can be
no debate there can be no compromise
there can be no conversation instead
it's just a matter of who wins and who
loses and everything is on the table
that is the end of Republican
conversation I mean smart republican
conversation so as much as I care about
Republican policies and I do as much as
I care about conservative policies and I
certainly do the predicate for all of
that is a functioning system a
functioning polity and I fear that the
the the fraying is is growing at an
extraordinarily rapid rate okay time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate okay things that I like
today let's talk about the formation of
this country
so James Madison kept great notes on the
formation of the country at the
Constitutional Convention in 1789 7 1787
to 1789 and the the notes are quite
wonderful there is an edition of them
that you can get online edited by Edward
Larson and Michael Winship talking about
how the nation was formed do you think
that there weren't significant
disagreements among the people who were
at the Constitutional Convention read
the records people were were raging at
each other people couldn't stand each
other
people thought that that the system
could turn into a full-on tyranny they
just fought a war I mean there were
significant arguments but there was a
fundamental recognition that they were
all part of the same cause and I fear
that we are losing that fundamental
recognition and again that recognition
does not require that you believe that
Ilhan Omar believes in the same causes
you do I don't believe she believes in
the same causes that you do but I
believe that the cause itself which is
that people who disagree should not be
deported is more important than whatever
L had Omar things made agreement to
disagree lies at the fundamental root of
the country and then it's a question of
how do you convince people through
conversation and through social measures
how do you convince people to believe in
virtue now I may be reaching the post
liberal era where the only thing that
matters is everybody agreeing with you
but I think that it requires both I
don't think you can discard liberalism
the idea that people are allowed to
disagree and keep the virtue and I don't
think that you can describe the virtue
and keep the liberalism I think that the
left basically wants to discard the the
virtue and keep the liberalism and the
right some on the right one is this kind
of liberalism and keep the virtue I
don't think that these mutually
supportive bulwarks can maintain I don't
know one country can maintain in the
absence of either one of those those
poles okay time for a quick thing that I
hate
okay so there is a piece in the New York
Times Magazine called I wanted to know
what white men thought about their
privilege so I asked by a Yale professor
of poetry named Claudia Rankine and the
piece is not very good it is
extraordinarily long it's not very good
and she talks at the beginning about all
of the various writers that she's that
she's read and recommended to her class
she's talked about the history of racism
in the United States obviously she says
I needed to slowly unpack and understand
how whiteness was created how did the
Naturalization Act of 1917 90 which
restricted citizenship to any alien
being a free white person develop over
the years into our various immigration
acts what has it taken to cleave
citizenship from free white person what
was the trajectory of the KKK after its
formation at the end of the Civil War
what was his relationship to the Black
Codes
those laws subsequently passed in
southern states now listen I'm all for
knowing American history and for looking
at the ugly parts of American history
and for recognizing the role of the KKK
and the role of white supremacy and all
of this I think that's very important I
think that reading that into modern
American history and suggesting there is
innately a relationship between the
Naturalization Act of 1790 and becoming
a citizen in 2019 is a massive massive
stretch but that's not what is I think
silly about the piece the part that is
silly
about the piece is that this lady just
tells a bunch of stories about her
confrontations in Airport lines that's
really all the pieces it's just she saw
a white guy in a line and he did
something she didn't like and then she
either had a conversation or didn't and
this is supposed to tell us something
deep about white privilege so she says I
hesitated when I stood in line for a
flight across the country and a white
man stepped in front of me he was with
another white man excuse me I said I'm
in this line he stepped behind me but
not before for saying to his flight mate
you never know who they're letting in to
first-class these days she says was his
statement of defensive movement to cover
his rudeness and embarrassment or were
we sharing a joke perhaps he too had
heard about the recent anecdote in which
a black woman recalled the white woman
stepping in front of her at the gate
when the black woman told her she was in
line the white woman responded that it
was the line for first class was the
man's comments a slight reference but he
wasn't laughing not even a little not
even a smile
deadpan later when I discussed this
moment with my therapist she told me she
thought the man's statement was in
response to his flight mate not me I
didn't matter to him she said that's why
he could step in front of me in the
first place
his embarrassment if it was
embarrassment had everything to do with
how he was seen by a person who did
matter his white male companion I was
allowing myself to have too much
presence in his imagination she said
should this be a comfort was my total
invisibility preferable to a targeted
insult if you want to look for instances
of American racism and people who are
racist in America there are instances if
you are talking to your therapist about
that time a guy said something means you
in an airport line it's called welcome
to being at an airport I have very
little doubt that this person would have
said the same thing if this were a white
lady because he was called out for being
a jerk and then who's embarrassed at
being called out for being a jerk but
let's assume that he's a racist what
does that say about deep-seated American
racism not much it says that this guy's
a racist
maybe says that he's a jerk but this is
but she that this article is an exercise
in navel-gazing and trying to discern
American history and the role of
American history by looking at your
belly button like that really is what
this article is it's not a systematic
review of evidence it's not an
examination of data it is all narrative
stories that can be interpreted in
several different ways and then we're
supposed to take away from this that her
particular perspective on American
racism is the correct one and she talks
about she talks about all of this she
says how angry could I be at the white
man on the plane
the one who glanced at me each time he
stood up on the way he stood up the way
you look at a stone you had tripped on I
understood that the man's behavior was
also his socialization so now it's not
that the guy is responsible for being a
racist it's that all of society is
responsible for this guy being a racist
but don't worry she has other stories
from the airplane really that's the
thing it's it's thousands of words long
all about this woman's the CL professors
stories from being treated nastily on an
airplane although I will say some of
these stories don't look great for her
she says I was waiting in another line
for access to another plane in another
city as another group of white men
approached when they realized they would
have to get behind a dozen or so people
already in line they simply formed their
own line next to us I said to the white
man standing in front of me now that is
the height of white male privilege he
laughed and remained smiling all the way
to his seat he wished me a good flight
we had shared something I don't know if
it was the same thing for each of us the
same recognition of racialized privilege
but I could live with that polite form
of unintelligibility no probably he was
laughing and he thought that you were
joking because he thought you've got to
be kidding
right like that no one would be that
self-serious again have you ever been in
an airport people are insanely rude at
airports it is what they do and people
are constantly forming lines to the side
and airports and doing rude things and
so if somebody turned to me in the and
and there was like a separate line
forming and I was in it you know like
that's the height of white male
privilege everybody like really
seriously it is an airport where people
are rude but apparently this is the the
old Adam Carolla line that if you are
black and you're pulled over by a cop
unfairly your immediate response is
probably to think because of the
narrative and because of American
history it's because law enforcement is
racist if you're waiting you're pulled
over by a cop wrongly your first
instinct is say it's because the guy's a
jerk now as much of their money more
jerks than racists in American life so
statistically speaking it is more likely
the person to jerk that's the same thing
in this particular case she's I found
the suited men who refused to fall in
line exhilarating and amusing as well as
obnoxious watching them was like
watching a spontaneous play about white
male privilege in one act i appreciated
the drama one or two of them chuckled at
their own audacity she said the people
in my line almost all white and male
themselves were and turned quizzical and
accepting so hold on a second they
formed a separate line that was largely
white and male and it was next to
another line that was basically white
male except for the one black lady and
the other line was the white supremacist
line how we know it wasn't your line
that you were standing like how do we
know this she said as I watched this
scene play out I filed it away to use as
an example in my class how would my
students read this moment some would no
doubt be enraged by the white female
gate agent who let it happen
I would ask why it was easier to be
angry with her than with the group of
men because she didn't recognize or
utilize her institutional power my
goodness my goodness hey and then good
news there are more airport stories this
is it this continues as I became more
and more frustrated with myself writes
this Yale professor for avoiding asking
my question I wondered if presumed
segregation in business her first class
should have been number 47 on mcintoshes
list Macintosh's the creator of white
privilege just do it I told myself just
ask a random white guy how he feels
about his privilege on my next plan I
came close
I was a black woman in the company of
mostly white men in seats that allowed
for both proximity and separate spaces
the flight attendant brought drinks to
every
around me but repeatedly forgot my
orange juice telling myself orange juice
is sugar and she might be doing the
post-cancer body a favor I just nodded
when she apologized the second time
the third time she walked by without the
juice the white man sitting next to me
said to her and this is incredible you
have brought me two drinks in the time
you have forgotten to bring her one she
immediately returned with the juice I
thanked him he said she isn't suited to
her job I didn't respond she didn't
forget your drinks she didn't forget you
you are just seated next to no one in
this no place instead I just said she
likes you more so her what she what she
wanted to respond was that she was being
ignored by the stewardess because she
was black right she didn't forget you
it's because I'm no.1 in her eyes how do
you know she's not just a bad stuff
flight attendant hey when when you were
trying to mind-read people you very
often end up in the worst places so
instead she says I said she just likes
you more he perhaps thought I was
speaking about him in particular and
blushed did he understand I was joking
about white male privilege it didn't
seem so right because who jokes about
white male privilege like is this all
this lady jokes about her comedic
repertoire needs some work
he brought both hands up to his cheeks
as if to hold in the heat of this
embarrassing pleasure coming or going he
has changing the subject I'm returning
from Johannesburg really he said I was
just in Cape Town hence your advocacy I
thought ungenerously
why was that thought in my head I myself
am over determined by my race is that
avoidable is that a problem had I made
this the prow had I made the problem
when was I given the problem well you're
making a problem now so far the guy said
nothing offensive and he's defended you
from what stewardess who's not getting
you a drink she says I'm the long flight
I didn't bring up white male privilege
jokes or otherwise again instead we
wandered around our recent memories of
South Africa and discuss the resort
where he stayed in the Safari
I took she's back home when I mentioned
these encounters to my white husband he
was amused he said they're just
offensive white fragility he added with
what so the guys white fragility he's
what he was defending you and he's still
somebody who's suffering from white
fragility okay so then we come to the
culminating story of this asinine piece
in The New York Times Magazine from a
Yale professor again quote I finally got
up my nerve to ask a stranger directly
about white privilege as I was sitting
next to him at the gate it initiated our
conversation because he was frustrated
about yet another delay we shared that
frustration together eventually he asked
what I did I told him I write and teach
where do you teach he asked Yale I
answered he told me his son wanted to go
there but hadn't been accepted during
the early application process it's tough
when he can't play that
city card he added was he thinking out
loud where the words just slipping out
before he could catch them was this the
innocence of white privilege was he
yanking my chain
was he snapping the white privilege flag
in my face should have I have asked him
why he had it expectation his son should
be admitted early without delay without
pause without waiting you know if I ever
asked how he knew a person of color took
his son seat and not another white son
of one of these many white men sitting
around us well yellow has an affirmative
action program that's what he's talking
about
there's legalized racism at many
institutions of higher learning there's
instant you want to talk about
institutional racism it is endemic
institutional racism to favor people of
one race over another race solely on the
basis of that race that is what he is
talking about and he is correct that
when you go to Ivy League schools there
is a determined attempt to bring in
people of particular races by race by
the administrators at these schools that
is what he is talking about that does
not make him a racist that means that he
is pointing out an obvious fact that has
been true since Bakke in the United
States it's been true for literally
decades that if colleges are admitting
people on the basis of race then that
means that other peoples are being
excluded on the basis of race then
League I tried to walk it back right he
said the Asians are flooding the Ivy
League's he tried to walk it back so
he's not talking about affirmative
action now listen is where he gets to be
racist okay it's not racist to say my
son isn't playing the diversity car
because he can't write it is racist to
say the Asians are flooding the Ivy
League's that's racist because Asians
aren't flooding the Ivy League's
qualified people are flooding the Ivy
League's and many of those people happen
to be disproportionately Asian right
it's actually racist of the
administration at Harvard to say we have
too many Asians here we can't allow
enough in that's racist so it's racist
when the guy says the Asians are
flooding the Ivy League's but she's
happy with this she goes perhaps the
clarification was intended to make it
clear that he wasn't speaking right now
about black people and their forms of
affirmative action he had remembered
something
he had recalled who was sitting next to
him that did it I asked I've been
thinking about white male privilege and
I wonder if you think about yours or
your sons it almost seemed to be a non
sequitur be rolled with it he said not
me I've worked hard for everything I
have and then she goes on to talk about
how no white man has actually worked
hard for everything that he has this was
what was it that justice Brett Cavanaugh
said at his Supreme Court confirmation
hearing I got into Yale Law School
that's the number one law school in the
country
I had no connections there I got there
by busting my tail in college he
apparently believed this despite the
fact that his grandfather once he
I couldn't tell by looking at the man I
was sitting next to but I wondered if he
was an ethnic white rather than a white
anglo-saxon Protestant you understand
how dumb it is to think like this and
how ugly it is to think like this in the
United States and if you say I worked
really hard to get where I've gone that
somebody looks really say really what
color are you that's that's how this
works
demonstrate how my Jewish family is
benefiting from white privilege now if
you want to say that there is systemic
racism that has existed in the United
States against black folks and you also
want to say that that has outsized
impact over time I think that's an
argument that can be made although I
think that you'd have to argue about the
outsized impact like what is the actual
impact how much of it is personal
decision-making differentials in
personal decision-making post 1965 how
much of it is the legacy of slavery or
Jim Court like those are all good open
arguments well you know what is not a
good arguments of people you accomplish
something in your life that's cuz you're
white that is a very very bad argument
and it's a very ugly and untrue argument
generally because white people don't
just hand other things to hand other
things to white people on the basis of
white people being white if they do then
that's racism and you can call out the
racism for the racism but I guess the
idea is that Brett Kavanaugh what didn't
work hard that this guy did not work
hard she said I said to the man what if
I said I wasn't referring to generations
of economic wealth to Mayflower wealth
and connection she said I asked it I
asked him if he gets flagged when he
passes through TSA not usually he said I
have Global Entry so do I said but I
still get stopped and then this
apparently he's supposed to what
acknowledge that racial profiling at TSA
is is a true and obvious phenomenon on
the basis of her personal experiences if
your argument boils down to my personal
experience your truth it's not a very
good argument you need some data for all
of this then finally she concludes not
long after this I was on another flight
so all she does is take flights and
talks to and talk to white people about
white privilege seems like a pretty
terrible job she says not long after
this I was on another flight and sitting
next to a white man who felt as if he
could already be a friend our
conversation had the ease of kicking a
ball around on a fall afternoon we were
just having a great time
he asked my favorite musician was I told
him the Commodores because of one song
night shift which is basically an elegy
he loved Bruce Springsteen but night
shift was also one of his favorite songs
eventually he told me he'd been working
diversity inside his company we still
have a long way to go he said then he
repeated himself we still have a long
way to go adding I don't see color and
then she says the phrase I don't see
color pulled an emergency break in my
mind why would you be bringing up
diversity if you didn't see color I
wondered would you tell your wife you
had a nice talk with a woman or a black
woman help all I could think to say was
ain't I a black woman okay like okay I
don't know how you have a conversation
with a person like this I really don't
Claudia Rankine the professor Yale
because everything you do is going to be
psychoanalyzed for a thousand reasons
and without any truth to it it's her
projecting her own vision of what you
should be on to you or what you are
truly saying on to you this is one of
the things that separates Americans from
Americans is the determination to
attribute motives to people without
proper evidence for those motives that's
a good example if I want to say that ill
gente Mars an anti-semite I think it's
pretty obvious from all of her behavior
and all of her statements like all of
them consistently for years if you want
to say that the guy's probably a
beneficiary of white privilege and
racism because he says he doesn't see
color I'm gonna suggest that that's way
worse for the country and an actual
problem for the country okay well we
will be back here a little bit later
today with two additional hours of
content or we will see you tomorrow here
on the bench appear Oh show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
hey everybody its Andrew Klavan host of
the Andrew Clavin show trumps crowds are
angry about Ilhan Omar and they're
chanting send her back
should we clutch our pearls thump our
chests thump are pearls clutch our
chests sounds like a porn film but we'll
figure it out
plus it's mailbag day on the Andrew
Klavan show